all right we're live on the YouTube
people coronavirus central here in Los
Angeles we are we are in lockdown over
here and I know many of you are in
lockdown wherever you are
you know especially if you're in big
cities it seems like we're being locked
down but of course this is not just the
United States thing India last night
issued major lockdown orders it's
happening all over the world obviously I
don't have to explain again what's going
on in China itself and what's going on
in South Korea and Italy especially with
with their elderly population I mean
there's a lot of craziness going on
I did a livestream on Monday and
basically what I was trying to say to
you guys is I'm really really gonna do
my best not to add to the craziness
right now I'm really trying not to do it
on Twitter I'm trying to get out of the
partisan nonsense and the rest of it and
I think all of us whether you work at
home like I do normally right my Studios
in my house my crew comes here my home
is my office we have several people that
work here all the time whether you're
someone that works at home all the time
or you're somebody that's now working at
home for the first time or maybe you
have a parent in your house or maybe you
have kids and mouse for the first time
while you're working or the the
multitude of situations I think we're
all going through a truly shared
experience like has not happened
possibly ever before well for sure ever
before because of the way we can now
communicate this way right through the
internet but this type of thing there
have been pandemics throughout time
there have been times when people have
been quarantined there's been times of
mass disease and sickness and death and
all of those things but we're in a
particularly unique time when you add in
the technological aspect of it and the
rest and then you throw social media on
it and the way that everyone behaves and
everything else and I just feel like if
I can do any minor thing to make
everybody's situation a little bit a
little bit better at this time it'll be
that I'll try to have a little a little
sanity right now I'll try to add a
little humor you know we've been doing a
lot of interesting things we've been
doing movies movies with the Rubin
Report community and we're gonna do a
dinner night where we all cook the same
thing and chattin a whole bunch of other
stuff so what I'm doing for now on is
every Monday and Wednesday at 8:45 a.m.
Pacific 11:45 a.m. East
I'm bringing back the direct message
many of you guys may remember that I
used to do at the top of every show I
used to do a five minute direct message
I would write it out usually the day
before and then I would read it directly
off the off the prompter here and then
when I started writing my book last year
it just it just became impossible on top
of touring and everything else like I
just we just had to drop that and it was
really unfortunate because that was
where I really got to share my thoughts
in the cleanest clearest possible way
with you guys as opposed to an interview
and I'm focusing on someone else's
thoughts alright somebody else's ideas
and I really missed that over the last
you know year year and a half or so and
now that the books done and as most of
you guys know don't burn this book comes
out on April 28th you can get it on
Amazon and the rest of the stuff I
thought we should be doing this now so
we're gonna do it every Monday every
Wednesday I'm gonna take questions that
you guys submit at Rueben report comm we
already got a whole bunch here and then
we're gonna consider doing a live Skype
call and show weekly as well there's
some technical stuff we're working out
you know the internet in LA right now is
really really terrible so I hope the
quality that you're seeing right now is
pretty decent we did this on Monday and
it was all banged up we've got some
people here that are gonna climb on the
roof today and add some satellite stuff
like we're investing by the way I want
to welcome our newest hire we just hired
Michael Frank he is our new associate
producer so we're expanding here and
we're trying to figure out how to get
through the madness like everybody else
so I just want to give you one direct
point and then I want to get to your
questions but before I do anything else
Clyde Clyde the people want to see it I
know the people want to see them that's
mostly why people have tuned in in case
you missed it the other day
come on Clyde what are you doing what
are you doing yeah we adopted Clyde on
Saturday
what are you doing fired what are you
doing what do they say about keeping a
dog in studio probably not the greatest
idea in the world
Clyde what's up come here for one sec
I'm also wearing Clyde socks in honor of
Clyde that's Clyde the glide Drexler
right there and there all right you'll
come back when you want in any event we
adopted Clyde on Saturday he was about
to be put down which is crazy he's just
awesome wonderful amazing loving dog and
you know all the shelters were closing
and they're gonna have to put down dogs
so he
Clyde and you know we're doing all right
over here
now you want to see camera shot right
now all right he's camera shy it's all
good so so the main point that I want to
make before I dive into into the
questions today my main direct message
and I know some of the questions are
about this specifically but I want to
talk about this stimulus package a
little bit because there's a lot of
weirdness out there right now you see
people that are generally you know
libertarian minded classical liberals
small government people suddenly
demanding the government do all sorts of
crazy things and then even now the
government I believe should be doing
something right now we should not be
doing something that is never going to
end we should not be giving universal
basic income forever we should not be
just pumping money into things that we
know don't need the money which of
course is what this entire bill is about
so I thought I'd read to you a couple of
the things that are in the bill that are
that are quite quite curious so first
off there's some good things some bad
things and as I said I believe the
government has to do something temporary
and you know I talk about this all the
time people always say to me Dave what
is the difference between a libertarian
and a classical liberal and I would just
say a classical liberal
is a little bit more of a realistic
libertarian where a true libertarian
that wouldn't want the state to do
anything except protect property rights
and you know make sure we all have equal
rights which is which we're both by the
way very very lofty and wonderful goals
what a what a classical liberal would
say is we do need some governmental
guardrails whether we like it or not
that that's the position that I start
all of these arguments from so a couple
of things that are in the two
trillion-dollar stimulus bill there'll
be two drew two direct payments two
rounds of it to taxpayers on April 6th
and May 18th
that's that that's gonna cost 250
billion dollars each this info is from
Axios by the way there will be a fifty
billion dollar bailout for the airline
industry that's from Axios as well and a
hundred fifty billion two other
industries affected including hotels
casinos cruise line operators and
shopping mall operators now we can all
debate we can have this great debate and
we should have it honestly this great
debate as to should we be bailing out
giant companies
like this or giving money directly to
the people is there some version where
we can do both of those things but think
about the airline industries right now
right like the idea of okay just let
them fail just absolutely just let them
crumble well nobody's flying right now
right flights are at like two percent
capacity flights are being canceled left
and right if the airline industry
absolutely collapses we got a big
problem on our hands now I know what the
truest free-market people would say is
well you just let it happen and then
eventually when we get out of this mess
human ingenuity and competition and the
marketplace and everything else will
will sort of rejigger the economy so
that we'll have new ways of thinking
about all these things I actually think
that there's a lot of that but could the
government do something to keep some of
these businesses in place right because
it you can't just it's sort of like you
can't go from something that basically
works to absolutely nothing and again I
get the libertarian argument here
they're arguing is you gotta let things
all right it's not as if the
too-big-to-fail thing worked right we we
pump money into banks because they were
too big to fail and then we just made
them bigger so now we have even more
reason not to let them fail so these are
all interesting arguments by the way you
don't really hear any of these arguments
on CNN or Fox or ever do you and maybe
on Fox actually Tucker's been talking
about this but you're certainly not
going to hear these arguments on MSNBC
what you're gonna hear is oh the evil
Republicans stopped the you bill from
passing Mitch McConnell's evil even
though a couple of the things that have
that have popped into this thing Native
American casinos have requested 18
billion dollars due to this whole thing
museums
did you see the tweet by Jerry Nadler
who's a congressman in New York he wants
to give four billion that's billion with
a baby he wants to give four billion
dollars to keep New York City museums
open apparently there's about a hundred
New York City Museum most of them have
huge endowments by the way and tons and
tons of money that they are that donated
to them but he thinks that because of
coronavirus to keep these business these
not businesses these nonprofit museums
going four billion dollars does that
seem of high priority I love museums
most of my tried
incredible childhood memories of going
with my great-grandma and my grandma and
my great grandfather and my great-great
aunt all the time and I've since taken
my nieces and nephews they're gone by
myself sometimes I love the Museum of
Natural History I love museums in
general love that big freaking whale
everybody loves the way I love that gem
room but I don't think that right now in
light of economic collapse worldwide
pandemic never those we should be
worried about giving money to museums we
could close the museum's they're closed
right now close them for a while and
then let's figure out but this is what
the government does with everything
oh just pump more money into every just
keep taking money from the people how
about we just let the people have their
money I think you know what to do with
your money I want to cut taxes for
everybody so you have more money you
want to do some things so that people
have some have some ability to pay their
rent pay their mortgages you know eight
I mean we're trying to figure out some
things right now I'll be totally honest
with you guys I always try to be you
know want all of my employees my
full-time employees are obviously there
on contract they're all being paid
although they're nobodies here right now
right now we're not letting anybody into
the house since why I'm doing this for
my computer but we have some contract
employees so for example my my makeup
girl Alexis who we love who I've been
working with for five plus years I
obviously don't have makeup on right now
and it's just because we don't want
extra people coming in the house now
that means she's not getting paid her
other gigs by the way our TV gigs that
the shows aren't shooting so she doesn't
have that so we're trying to figure out
how we can help her in the short term
whether that's loans or whatever I
actually think that that's how most of
this should operate like we're okay
right now as long as the internet keeps
working although we'll see how long that
goes but these crazy things
Amtrak wants a billion that the same
argument that I made about the planes I
think is relative to Amtrak it's like
what do we let these things collapse or
not I don't think we can let things
fully collapse but we'll go from there
all right so what I am gonna do with
these direct messages I think I shared
my general thoughts on the stimulus
package hopefully they'll get some of
the pork like this is why everyone hates
politicians Pelosi Schumer all of you
guys this is why everyone hates you even
in times of true crisis this is when we
need
right I want a government so small that
you people should have nothing to do
with my life or anyone else's life but
since we don't have exactly what I want
even though that's what the founders of
the Constitution wanted you guys at this
very moment if you can never be good if
you can never put the people's needs
above your pet project needs maybe this
is the one time you should do it right
Nancy are you watching Chuck Loretta and
by the way this is a by partisan thing
McConnell whoever else put the people
ahead of you right now strip all of the
pork out of there strip the four billion
for the museums oh by the way they put
in a diversity and inclusion initiative
in there so all of the someone's gonna
have to clarify the exact parts of this
but all of the institutions that take
the stimulus money will have to have
dirt diversity and inclusion programs I
mean the whole thing is bananas it is
absolutely bananas this has nothing to
do with helping people on top of like
the series of other idiotic things that
you see politicians talking about aoc
tweeted out this morning this thing
about we should be releasing prisoners
from Rikers Island because some of the
prisoners and staff have coronavirus and
they're not six feet apart from each
other so we should release these people
Dakar Sorrell that they ad Carson right
or so she made up a word also but but
release these people into the population
that make sense so forgetting that
they're criminals let's just put that
aside but potentially they also have
coronavirus what's the best thing we
could do put them out at the same time
while we've got you know mayors of
cities saying we're gonna stop selling
firearms to people so let's have people
stop being able to protect themselves
and let's put more criminals out there
who are potentially sick you can't make
this up I mean we're in a clown show of
epic proportions but I do think kamar
heads can prevail as long as all of us
keep talking we gotta keep doing this
you got to keep spreading your voice and
fight fighting the power man alright so
I want to get to to a couple of your
questions so when I when I do these
direct messages every Monday Wednesday
8:45 a.m. and as I said we're gonna try
to do some Skype call and shows with you
guys as well I'm taking questions only
submitted at Rubin report calm so you
can create a free account sign in and
then you basically pay what you want and
then we all get to your questions I just
can't open this up to YouTube and
Twitter and Facebook and everybody
just a insanity to fight through and the
trolls and the bots and we've we've
built a really great community there
that I think I think is really
worthwhile in a time like this so when I
do these videos I'm gonna do them for
about 20 minutes each I've already
gotten about 14 minutes here but I'm
gonna try to do half direct message and
then half get into your question so I
want to get to some of your questions
right now so let's see do you agree with
James Lindsay that the social justice
ideology only going to continue to
capitalize on the current pandemic and
its effects or do you think it's being
forced at by more practical concerns so
that's a great question I'll try and do
it pretty quick what I would say is you
know I tweeted at the beginning of the
year that this is the year that social
justice collapses I don't think it can
survive the weight of an election year
and that all of us are finally waking up
to it cancel culture people are now
fighting against it I think what's
happening right now is the average
person let's say you were you're not
like sort of where I'm guessing most of
my audiences which is you see canceled
culture you see social justice as the
evil monster that it is but let's say
you've sort of been on the fence or not
paying attention or you were a little
kind of like what is that thing
something ain't right I think now
because we have real problems now that
you're suddenly gonna go oh the social
justice stuff is all nonsense those are
not real problems those are made up
privileged problems you have the
privilege of having these idiotic social
justice problems because you have a
pretty damn good right now we have real
problems and it's gonna look pretty too
idiotic do you care what the color or
gender or sex of the person who's gonna
solve the coronavirus problem is or do
you not if you don't care what it is
then you're not you don't care about
social justice social justice I don't
care if someone's got a good idea right
now that a good products can help us in
any way I don't care what gender or sex
or anything else they are right and I
don't think you do either so I think
social justice in many ways will
collapse on itself however I'm guessing
James made this point they always double
down into themselves so every time they
lose or every time someone comes against
them they use that as more fuel to prove
that they are right and the evil
patriarchy is coming and everyone else's
against them so I don't think they will
go quietly but I think the average
and by the way this has been happening
for a long time the average person is
waking up and realizing this is nonsense
Jessica says how did you and David pick
Clyde's name it was in honor of my
favorite basketball player Clyde the
glide Drexler right there and we saw
Clyde jumping around and he's smooth man
this guy this dog flies well he glides
he glides so Clyde the glide there you
go let's see what do you miss is
adrianne what do you miss most from the
pre coronavirus world what do you miss
most from the pre coronavirus world well
I guess I mean you know one of the
things I've been thinking about is that
you know there's this question that I
think we're all subtly asking ourselves
even if we're not thinking about it that
much there's this question of like are
things ever gonna get back to normal
right and what is normal anymore you
know and I sort of you know I normally
ain't that bad
you know we run around complaining about
everything all the time and this is an
affliction of the West in many ways we
all complain about all this stuff well
it's never been better in capitalism as
has brought more people out of poverty
and all the goodness and I'll give a
shout out to - Lucia who's in the Rubin
report community we did we all watched
idiocracy the other day and we did it
did a giant zoom chat and I would love
for more of you guys to be part of that
we had dozens of people in there it was
great we did a zoom chat afterwards all
talking about the movie and Lucio is
talking we also we're talking about
Corona obviously and Lucia was telling
us how she's in Argentina and she
watches Americans for the first time
seeing shortages of paper towels and
toilet paper and she's like boy you guys
don't know how good you have it that
happens all the time down here
so I think I think I miss a little of a
normalcy but what I'm hopeful for is I
think a lot of this is going to give us
some good perspective on on how we all
want to be you know like have have
enough supplies in your house I
understand that you have to protect
yourself understand that you know the
same people that are now demanding the
government do everything are the same
people who've been telling you that the
guy in charge of government Trump is
Hitler it's like well maybe then you
don't want to give the Hitler guy
although obviously I don't believe he's
Hitler or anything even remotely close
to that and that's the worst sort of
cultural appropriation actually maybe
you wouldn't want to give him so much
power so I think there's a unique
opportunity to get people to really
start
thinking about what they truly believe I
know I've been doing it and I hope and I
think you guys have been doing it as
well is it time to take Trump
derangement syndrome more seriously this
is Truman the media's dishonest coverage
of those people talk of the people
taking the chloroquine phosphate fish
tank cleaner will legitimately cause
many people not to trust medical advice
coming from the krona task force yeah so
I'm sure most of you saw this these
these two poor people they heard
something about chloroquine and then
they ended up drinking fish tank cleaner
I have the exact stuff here for my betta
fish and then everyone basically said
well Trump killed these two people and
it's like really like you guys just
couldn't possibly be worse so your
question is should we take Trump
derangement syndrome more seriously I
mean look I see this the people that
that endlessly endlessly rail against
Trump it's like we're all in this
together right now this guy is the pilot
of the plane or the captain of the ship
and right now I don't have Trump grains
Bench syndrome I think he's done a lot
of good in a way I think he's fought the
media in a way whatever the guy's not
perfect blah blah blah I want this ship
to be okay I don't want to hit that
freaking iceberg and I don't think most
people want it so I think these people
are becoming partisan and ridiculous and
and silly right now the worst type of
people right now are just the same old
partisans like we've got to start
thinking about things in a new way okay
we're trying to keep these all to 20
minutes so I'm going to just do one more
which is oh it's related to the format
of everything I'm doing here the
question from at a is will these be
released as podcasts yes so we're gonna
release all of these as audio podcasts
as well so in addition to the regular
show and this week I interviewed Dennis
Miller which was really interesting and
it was nice to get away from some of
this stuff we actually shot it right
before the corona stuff really exploded
so we didn't even get into that we
talked about comedy and he told me a
great story about Sinatra at the end and
a bunch of other stuff but yes we will
release these as audio podcasts and okay
it's been 20 minutes I hope this was
just like a little bit of break of some
sanity in your day um please join us at
Rubin report.com
or you can search the iOS app the Apple
app or in Google Play Android in the
Google Play Store
we're building a great community that's
how I'm trying to communicate directly
with you guys it's just too much on on
Twitter in the youtube comment section
and everything else we're sharing
recipes we're sharing music we're
talking to each other were debating
politics it's respectful
there's no trolls it's all good guys so
I hope you're all well I hope
everybody's good and you know just stay
safe stay sane follow the directions for
now and let's keep talking about this
stuff and see what happens all right and
remember every Monday Wednesday 8:45
a.m. Pacific and 11:45 a.m. Eastern and
thank you guys and that's it all right